hey guys welcome back to big moon back
on the set we're still so so excited to
be back here we are done with those zoom
episodes I loved it because we would
start at 5:30 p.m. it's true now that
we're back in the studio we're starting
at 10:00 at 7:30 to me - oh it was a bit
of a [ __ ] but we are very happy to be
on set also because we get to have more
guests now and today we have a very very
special guest oh yay thank you for
having me back
you changed last week you look kind of
comfy last time okay
I'm wearing my onesie under this well
today we wanted to actually I brought
this one up because my birthday's coming
up and I thought of what we did last
year all the girls took me out to a gay
club in West Hollywood we won't see
itself I went to the abbey if anyone's
familiar with LA gay clubs the abbey is
like a huge big deal and I got a lap
dance by a very very sexy I'm almost
completely naked man shiny shiny
actually you bought so she [ __ ] she
pulled it out for my birthday last year
and I know that this year the clubs are
still not open and I will not get to
have the same kind of party but I wanted
to reminisce on like [ __ ] fun party
story there is still vomit on my shoes
from that night girl clean your shoes I
clean mine the next day we did a lot of
puking on the side of the road when you
guys go to male strip clubs are you
allowed to like touch the dicks is that
like part of it oh you never been I mean
I would never touch the dick but I but
they don't put that [ __ ] up in your feet
I know I know I do that bar you allowed
to touch well okay the one time I did go
oh no I've been there twice actually no
but anyway um the first time I went the
the dancer the go-go dancer he was like
really into dancing I was they were all
telling him like oh this is her first
time sin there
I've been to a gay strip club and all
this stuff and then so the guy ended up
getting my hands and like stuck it up in
his junk and then he was like wiggling
it and I was like oh so you are allowed
to touch the date what he did he grabbed
my let you I think it's like stripper
even female strippers right right the
bouncers are always like don't [ __ ]
touch but if the girl takes your hand
please and it's like yeah okay last
question never you know I've never I've
never been in wild that's obvious but
I've never been inside a male strip club
you should go Club and like we're in a
male yeah yeah so I have been to girls
strip clubs and usually it's like you
know you can you can touch and you know
and some of them they back there like
[ __ ] in the VIP so I'm like at the
guy strip clubs what okay please yes
tell me
so when you had your hand in the John
the junk was it in his speedos or was a
bare dick in your hand oh SP nose okay
you know and also they usually have like
two layers so they'll have like
something to kind of keep them fluffy
and then they have and then they have
like another thing over it so like Vacon
or like a [ __ ] ring or something like
big they stay fluffed and then they have
like another thing over it so it's like
two layers so I've never been to a male
strip club either because okay so you
know how like girls strip clubs there is
topless and there's full nude are there
full nude male strip clubs I've never
seen no it wasn't at my in the US but I
do have a story yes about a bachelorette
party I went to and we went to a male
strip club first and that was all great
it was like everything you see like in
the movies like Magic Mike or whatever
like it was just exactly like that [ __ ]
but then the bride took one of the
strippers home to the hotel and [ __ ]
him the night before they were supposed
to me I was know like in the movies yeah
she really straight-up did that [ __ ] and
I was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
and we had to go to the wedding and all
the girls were [ __ ] quiet issues the
same I don't know that we agreed yeah
exactly that was amazing
that happened to me I will wait until
the I Do's and announce it to everyone
but do you know like she for sure like
brought herpes or something to that
marriage like like you know a male
stripper they took home after the strip
club yay like you know maybe she walk on
him and it was super or he what Connor
was super safe was all good I'm sure
they if you're doing that right before
your wedding out you should probably
just well needless to say I found out
like two and a half years later they did
get divorced okay I was about to say cuz
you sharing this story right now and I
was like maybe you know do you my
friends from back then this was in Texas
like they're not watching this wedding
way no it's over so that was just a
clear sign I think I was karma sure but
yeah I don't know if the guy did
something similar to then I guess we
should go to a male strip club here cuz
I don't know if there are any here but
the one cuz the okay I did go do it for
science Kari Chinese oints and speedos
just I wanted I mean it's I don't see a
huge gigantic difference but I don't see
a huge difference between the female
ones and I've never been to a Magic Mike
kind of male strip club but because the
one I went to was more like a bar and
there was like go dancers there and
speakers kind of like my birthday is
that the Abbi is more of a club and then
they just have like they're like [ __ ]
15 guys like swinging from the ceiling
yeah it was kinda like that speakers
like cheer was supposed to go to a
bachelorette party at like a few years
ago and in Vegas and I knew part of the
plan was to go to a male strip club and
I was like alright cool I want you to
have fun I want you get the full
experience I was like I look man if
there's if there's a dick in your face I
don't mind if you if you grab it right
but I was like but don't stroke it I'm
like once there's movement in your arm
and it's a stroke I feel like that's a
little too much
you can rest assured I don't so for you
though was it the same was it like
mutual like she was like okay you could
have a titty in front of your face touch
it different though different digs it's
not the equivalent I mean yeah it's fine
if any you know I think um I think you
know she knows I've been to the strip
club with the homies on our case you
know when I was a baby together at the
strip club ya know we've been trying to
get her gum we always go strip club
sometime cuz I think they're fun yeah
we've never gone together she always
says she's down we just haven't actually
gone but I really think we're like you
wanna go to a strip club this weekend
you know is it's not really yeah every
time we end up at a strip club you know
right yeah we gone is just like and it's
never at home either cuz Casey and I
have been to to once in New Orleans and
then the other time in Vegas but it's
like oh we're here in this city let's go
see what a stripper like yeah you have
to like stumble your way into one if you
plan on going to a strip club I feel
like you're setting yourself up for like
oh like we're forcing the phone true
mm-hmm you wouldn't mind I just set up a
date know what cuz also because I feel
like Oh
first of all shrimp up food I heard his
fantastic up for two weeks of food is
good some of the best wings I've ever
had were at a strip club in Texas so
good and club sandwiches you know what
city you were in it was I'm like what if
it was the one I worked at okay
I've always wanted to go to the strip
clubs and all the rappers talk about
like Magic City oh it's different yeah
because you you girls would have more
fun at those ones yeah because it's more
about throwing a bunch of money and
watching the strippers do like
acrobatics and there's like two kinds of
clubs is that kind it was where it's
more like a party in a club and throwing
money to show off and then there's like
the strip clubs where you actually want
to go watch someone naked and it's like
they'll dance less but they get naked
you know and it's like it's quieter yeah
horny dudes they're going to the
the chill ones where it's like you
watching make it a little bit and then
you want to get a lap dance you know
it's like a lot of times the partier
ones sometimes they don't even like like
Sam's is super funds and Sam's HOF
Hofbrau in LA and it's a super fun
shrimp club it's like there's like eight
beautiful women on stage at once they're
not even naked they're usually just like
in thongs or whatever and everyone's
throwing money and it's fun and there's
not even really like a lap dance area
but then like when you go to the the
ones where you actually want to see
naked women there's like usually one or
two women on stage and it's just a
different atmosphere I think a lot
someone to show clothes in Vegas and I
think I bought Julia dance yeah everyone
lap dances and like trying to be like
the king of the strip club um so that
night I realize I'm [ __ ] picky yeah
okay yeah I took forever to find a girl
that I wanted and then once I got her
I'm like not even that good
I hate lazy strippers I had a lazy
stripper ones in Minnesota she sat down
my friend bought me a dance cuz I told
him I never got a dance me for it and we
really cared much for it she sat down
and she was I think she was tired eating
me and she goes oh my god just took
selfies and but these I strip clubs like
okay so I feel like we've all come from
pretty extensive partying backgrounds
mm-hmm any like crazy party stories well
I was thinking about this because I'm
the one that wanted to talk about it
because I miss like being in quarantine
has been like so sad for me I didn't
realize how much of a extrovert I really
am I thought I was an introvert I'm not
I realize my energy oh the people around
me it's just that I do need a lot of
time to rest
imagine still but it's not it's not like
her hybrid yeah I guess hybrid I'm the
awkward - I think I brew - yeah so I was
thinking about the crazy parties that
I've been to and I and I remember the
ones that stand out the most are like
the first time I tried any type of drug
like something new so I'm like the first
time I tried like
hot brownies the first time I tried with
what [ __ ] house mushrooms the first time
I did coke like all those are like those
are the craziest ones that I remember
but I mean have y'all done drugs at
parties absolutely yeah okay no no have
you have you never done any drugs
tonight ice I've smoked the occasional
on the rare occasion a little marijuana
but that's about it
those like did you ever go to the flower
parties cuz we lived near like I was
gonna flower parties just to like grind
on girls I wasn't really trying to do
drop contacts like flyer parties back in
the day before social media or when
social media was really like just
starting yeah people would print out
literal flyers to promote a party and
then there would be a lot of people
getting together and they would create
these party cruise so you'd be in a
party crew and then you'd have like your
nickname or whatever and then it even
got to put on people like bring out
their badges this was so like around
Linwood South gage must be a Nelly thing
won't be I think we had that in Texas I
mean I never knew anything no it was
always like that's kind of way you knew
the next like party was gonna be yeah so
then once you get a flyer like they'll
tell you like how much they're charging
at the door so people make money it was
like a hustle for like high school kids
what was your group name girl I I was in
two different party crews you know one
of them was from paramount which is
where it's in my life I think so
which was like the first party crew it
wasn't oh my god I feel so weird talking
I've talked about this before but for
some reason in this moment I feel like
major cringe but I mean it's funny when
you're doing yeah there's like I think
you're so cool it's like it's okay Lucas
no I was part of platinum ladies like
strippers I even made a song
way more to it that's just the part that
I remember is there any dance move no no
I presume can you put her in a song with
you yeah that'd be true the Platinum
lady dude it was so funny cuz the guy
from platinum guy or I forgot what
there's another platinum Venom fellas
fellas that was the one yeah cuz they're
from paramount so so you know this no no
I don't know that specific party crew
I'm familiar with the party crew kind of
like that live yeah yeah cuz every city
had like their like party crew that they
would rap - yeah if anything I remember
getting flyers you know you there was
always Flyers of like this is what a
party's gonna be at they would get some
like so just strangers are having ragers
yeah pretty much
do you get jumped into the crew like how
does this work ah no it's just like
someone that's in the crew they'd be
like oh I'm part of this crew do you
want to come and have fun at parties and
then we're like okay cool and then like
when you're part of the crew you get in
like okay so they'd be collabs kind of
like with this is amazing like
underground world so there'd be collabs
with other crews and like two crews
would be throwing this one particular
party so then whoever is part of that
crew gets to go into that that party for
free gets a free drinks free nods hello
ID cards ordered nas balloon nos nos
okay I talked about this recess like
dancing I guess that's what people will
call it the general public no so like
the not stank that they would actually
use for cars they fill up balloons with
that and would just inhale the balloon
and get [ __ ] up so that's why I've
lost so many brain cells but yeah so
like being part of those crews it would
get you into these parties and then like
you would also and then if your crew was
the one throwing the party you'd get a
cut out of the money that you make from
the party because there's like alcohol
being sold balloons this makes so much
more sense because when I was younger I
would hear I would listen to a lot of
music that would come out of the LA area
and they would be talking about just
like door fees or like charges to get it
like there would be some reference that
and I'm like who charges five dollars to
get into a party
I had a whole door my whole closet door
filled with all the Flyers that like all
the parties that I would go to and on
the Flyers it would specify like virgin
location which meant like no one like
there has not been a party thrown at
this location yet because every weekend
there'd be like four or five six
different parties going on and then like
a lot of them get raided
so you'd be jumping around from
different homes but anyway they would
actually say virgin location and my mom
she was like staring virgin party yes
she was like be funny
so Kissimmee fika like are you losing
your virginity at the party how many
times have you lost your virginity she's
like oh yeah like she would be like what
is what does this mean I remember
laughing mom it just means that they
haven't done her party at this place yes
like it does that supposed to be like oh
hey this is a virgin location so the
cops probably won't rate this likely
because it's not a known exactly here's
the thing it's like the Flyers were mad
legit but like there were literally just
house parties you know I'm saying like
it wasn't like a very you who says how
is Flyers for house parties how much of
a cut did you really get though how much
money were you guys making uh I
personally I don't think I ever made a
penny man like I was just like I'm sure
to [ __ ] get out of my house because
my house is toxic
I just want to escape and I want to
[ __ ] get high and drunk and not be at
home yes I have so many questions roll
that I have so many answers no okay so
these were like the two like a solid
year actually a solid year of my life
that I would be going to these parties
and so I had a had a curfew I need to I
need it to be home by 11:30 I think it
was and the [ __ ] party start like at
9:00 like it was super early so I would
get home I'd have someone dropped me off
and then wait for me around the corner
and then sneak out of my room and go out
of gas yes
I'm like I was such a bad kid but yeah I
would do that but then one time my mom
caught me because she was sleeping in
the bed waiting for me to come back
your mom's a gay yeah your bed my bed my
bed she was [ __ ] there like this
mission gonna walk now but yes I did I
snuck through the window I see her in my
bed and I sleep on the floor and I wake
up with her like beating my just
prolonged your punishment I did in the
next morning she's like you know you're
not having a door you don't deserve
privacy for this [ __ ] so I didn't have a
door for a whole month
she took the door off it took yeah and
then like now in like current mom's
shoes yeah I look back and I'm like damn
like what do you do at that point it's
funny that you talk about nos balloons
and stuff because so I'm someone who
worked in nightlife so partying was my
job motive but because it was my job I
didn't really party because for me it
was just work and then I remember I was
go-go dancing and then um I went
upstairs with my girlfriend who was
dancing with me and they were they were
blowing up balloons I was like no idiot
go you're [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't really
did you no no I'm gonna tell you what
she's like no that's not that that's
what those were drugs I was like oh okay
I had no idea but like because I was it
was weird um I I went to I started I
went to my first nightclub when I was 17
I snuck in and then I was kind of
whatever I didn't care about it and then
I started raving at like 17 and that's
when like the drug use third happening
what did you do all I cared about
listen to that music since I was like
nine kid like I loved it and I knew that
once I got old enough I'm like you don't
yup my young yeah you are you are you
right yeah right you know you're young
you know I used to be judgmental of it -
I'm like oh cuz my sister will listen to
it and I gotta go and I remember being
like 14 ish and then they'll be like
it'll you listen to techno no I live
there and I start going to raves and
then it's like psychedelic trance and
like
yeah there's certain kinds weren't like
uh so much obviously I like it in doses
yeah going um so I started raving at
like seventeen and that's when the drug
start happening like ecstasy because
I've been wondering about this since I
was kid like just goes hand in hand
together and I loved it and it's my
first Rea was EDC two thousand eight or
nine in LA which was amazing yeah it was
until last one that they had no
intentions like when house music's
really started getting commercial yeah
so this was like maybe 2007 that I went
but then I remember one night because my
friends and I would just like try out
new pills not even at a party was
randomly randomly just like this test
out these new ones at the house what did
you do cuz I cannot stay still just like
I always had to listen to music chill in
the room dance in the room just [ __ ]
vibe and then um and then one night we
just kept on chasing the high that night
I did the boost pills in my life that's
scary that's that's that scares me so
much oh my god what happened
I did eight and a half so I was Jean
Paul's from like 9:00 p.m. till 2:00 in
the afternoon the next day oh and then
my friends dropped me off at home and
then I got jumped off and then I
realized oh [ __ ] I need to lay down I
can't hear anything
my my hearing just went out damn and I
lay there for like three days like
couldn't
yeah like several days worth of drugs do
yeah you can get up every time I got up
my vision go all white and I can't see
and oh God
Jeff I was like alright we're gonna lay
back down it's like losing like your
blood pressure your blood pressures too
low no I got your brain [ __ ] just
completely dysfunction yeah so for three
days and my aunt was really chill like
she's whatever like you know this was
during the summer or whatever and then
after that I'm like okay so maybe I
shouldn't do yeah maybe not so um but
then the next year I started go-go
dancing when I was like 18 and then I
got scouted by insomniac and then
instead of gonna race for fun now I was
working them and then I remember the
first event that I did as as work of
course I would go sober and then I'll
just walk when I'm like oh my god is
this what I looked like when I see
[ __ ] terrible guys yella crazy we
look insane I got really jealous when I
found out that you were dancing for
cascade or something I was like I been
the best nights of my life I danced for
some of the greatest DJs parties like
that whole scene a lot of the girls end
up becoming go-go dancers so I was about
to become a go-go dancer to you yeah
because there was this guy that was I
guess he headed in with like some club I
don't even remember but the girl that
got me into platinum ladies she had just
turned 18 like right before or right
after like I got into that crew and so
since she had just turned 18 she started
go-go dancing for that club that this
one guy knew about and and then so she
told me she was like you know you can
make money and all this these things and
like I said I was just trying to get the
[ __ ] out of my house so I'm like money I
could make money this way yes and but
they were like no well you need to be 18
we have to make sure like it's legal so
I'm like [ __ ] I'm 18 and a year in some
months and so I like [ __ ] I'm gonna
do go a dancer as soon as I turn 18 but
instead I got pregnant better that you
didn't go that actually always say like
yeah no actually you kind of make me
change my mind because I used to think
back when you guys go completely exactly
I'm like I probably would have ended up
dead in a ditch or something especially
how many how many drugs I was doing like
how much escapism I was doing around
like I probably would have ended up a
stripper or something like something
crazy and F&E one of those things where
you have to have sound mind to like this
is just a job like I totally did it so
you make me think like see there's a
there's a positive out yeah I was just
thinking like I was so [ __ ] up there
was no like the risk of it is it's far
greater than you actually coming out
okay like Gina did yeah well I mean the
crazy thing is so like the first the
generation before me those go-go dancers
they were kind of they were kind of out
there like it was just it was the the
generation of girls that was like I'm
hot and I'm just gonna marry a rich dude
you know but then my generation we came
in I was dancing with like girls Marc
working on their masters degrees like
[ __ ] like really
educated good head on their shoulders
kind of girls but the girls before that
it was some of them some of them had
some issues they needed to work out like
just like rails of lines of coax the
coke in the bathroom all that was me I
was getting my masters and the first
time I ever gogo danced was in San
Francisco actually my girlfriend she was
a resident there she's like do you want
to try it and I'm like yeah whole outfit
yeah she had extra outfits I was like
let's furry boots a sexy little ass
cheeks hanging out I loved it and then
so we were dancing I remember it was a
club called glass cat in San Francisco
and there was a hanging cage that she
went up to dance on like we would have
to climb that [ __ ] get on there and I
was on the stage I loved it so much like
it was like non-stop and I was like oh
my kind of love this I get to wear cute
outfits I get to work out and don't be
[ __ ] touches me nobody talks to me
and then I started coughing really badly
like this sharp in my throat like it was
so bad I was like oh my god I have a
shape I'm only 18 what the [ __ ] and then
I looked up at my girlfriend and she's
like coughing - and just like what the
hell rival Club promoters whatever came
and pepper sprayed the whole club life
seriously that's better than it getting
shot true true so we had to evacuate and
then my girl she was like a lot older
than me she I was like 18 she's like 24
maybe and so we're like well [ __ ] what
do we do she doesn't [ __ ] go to his
ship club and she was that crazy horse
we went to crazy horse and she she was
like I'm gonna go throw money at these
strippers is my first time in a strip
club and crazy horse and San Francisco
and I was like okay and then the girls
strippers love women who throw money
right yeah and they lift up my girl's
skirt under our go-go dancing bikinis we
were the tiny panty thongs but go under
so just in case for any mistakes they
saw her underwear they're like stripper
panties and then that night was the
night that I found out that my
girlfriend sometimes
strips on the side for like amateur
night to win some money because next
thing you know my girls they have naked
on
and I'm just 18 years old like what the
[ __ ] then you entered no I see here's
the thing like even after years of
dancing and I think I can never be a
stripper because I am NOT I can't even
touch my ankles that's why the naked
ones clubs that I've been to they
haven't put on a show at all these girls
aren't even trying they're just like
this but saying like this sans is fine
yes I remember being so broke like 18 19
and trying to go to the club every week
though just so we could meet girls and
stuff and um like me and Rick my friend
Rick we know Rick oh yeah that's right
y'all were on the pocket love that guy
so me and Rick we would literally like
cuz you know I had my family's Thai food
restaurant and my mom would like no no
they were tired a few years ago so they
would let us have the cans and then so
we would take the cans cans one of just
like aluminum can make soda cans and
beer cans and [ __ ] like that used yeah
use cans so they would give us the cans
and so yeah so so when you recycle cans
if you if you send them if you put them
through the Machine individually like an
by bottle like or piece by piece you get
more money than giving them the big ass
bag yeah yeah yeah so like if you give
me a big ass bag they way at the little
bit of money right but I think when you
go to little machines you put them in
the machine or like certain supermarkets
there are these like recycling low like
huts and then you can either hand the
guy the bag or there's like I don't know
they still got him but back in the day
you could just take your bag open it up
and you could put each bottle and can't
do the thing and we thought that it
would get more money that way so we
would take our these [ __ ] big-ass
bought like bags of cans recycle money
so we'll get each have like 20 bucks to
get into the Google 20 40 bucks
we just wanna meet girls you know wait
do you remember cuz back in those times
wait back then cruisin was really
popular you guys never cruise you just
driving around just being in the car
yeah on Long Beach Boulevard this is the
most elation of ever so when I lived in
Mexico
I mean Mexico with the it's practically
Mexico born and raised born and raised
no so in Southgate they have like on
Long Beach Boulevard that's where there
would be traffic hour on Friday nights
but people would be there on purpose to
cruise and like hit up girls and like in
their cars yeah I mean I like the
freeway free-weight oh we didn't I
didn't even have a car
well I mean my car wasn't nice enough to
being all that you know I'm saying I
never really was a part of the crews
life we should go to clubs yeah 18 /
clubs and save money just to get in was
that just like the door fee was 20 bucks
yeah door fee was 20 bucks we didn't
drink not not till I was 21 that I
really started drinking oh yeah so
you're like yeah just a little like
under it like 18 flask or anything nice
you were just be in there trying to
dance so just have fun dancing you know
boys yeah I mean it was like we I mean
we're trying to mean ladies
that was it though like Oh as you got a
little older and you also got a little
bit more recognition did you do more
like with your party scene or nothing at
all you just always kind of sat to the
side a little bit I mean okay so when I
actually did like start drinking and
hitting up clubs and stuff no then then
and and when I could like afford to buy
alcohol you know we would definitely go
to the clubs pretty regularly so in our
group of homies it was uh we had we had
our boy Peter who was more of like he
liked like he wasn't a hip-hop guy so we
would go this club in LA called club
bang where they had a big hip-hop room
and then they also had no they had a big
like alternative like rock room I guess
you could say and then a hip-hop room on
the side so we'd all go in this big-ass
group Peter it would go to the like the
alternative room and then all the other
home he's going to hip hop room right so
we would definitely have a little drinks
and you know back then you never really
know what to drink you'd order [ __ ]
like adios blame [ __ ]
magic hurt on leaving yeah like all the
girls just get vodka sodas and it wasn't
til it wasn't so after I started like
doing shows and touring and stuff where
cuz I used to be like I would never
waste money on a bottle or a table like
I'm trying to be with the crowd and
dance and dance with girls and it wasn't
till I started doing like club shows or
like performing and we go to the
after-party where they gave us bottles
and gave us tables I was like this is
way better separated from the crowd is
that when you get older cuz I don't know
like maybe man cuz it's like be
comfortable when I was 18 I was like
looking at all the people like who
bought a thing and I'm like Yeller Chum
sale like aren't you dance you can't
dance is your city that's all I did
until recently because like I said I
only I worked so of course for people
who worked there we had our own tables
that's literally all I did that's all I
knew from the beginning until maybe like
last year like we were just chill at the
tables we didn't dance I just sat there
and looked good you're like dance for a
living
exactly and then it wasn't until like as
a recent last year like we would go and
then I'm like oh this is actually gonna
cool you get it you know dance with your
friends that's [ __ ] cool I mean I
mean people bother you but you know yeah
I used to be like I need to be in the
crowd [ __ ] sweating and it wasn't so
after like a year and a half of like
club life I was like I can't go to club
unless I got a table it just doesn't
feel right ya know which just pulled out
my phone and started playing best beans
so you guys know how much I love best
beans
so exactly that's what it would look
like you start busting out your phone
and playing best beans so if you're
looking for a fun way to pass the time
while engaging your brain and enjoying
breathtaking visuals and a gripping
story your answer is best beans so it's
a free download it's a unique and
exciting puzzle experience unlike any
other puzzle games and you guys have
heard me say this time and time again
I've been playing this game for I think
six years now five six years Christmas
yeah she knows me when I'm at her house
cuz she's just sitting there playing it
all day but yeah it's really cute
because they have these little fiends
and so these fiends they have these like
special powers that you can use in order
to in order to achieve the
end of the puzzle and so there's these
slugs that you have to defeat by using
these little fiends and I don't know
super cute and it's also really it's a
really great app for when you don't have
internet because you know there's no
like Wi-Fi required I love those yeah
you travel exactly but yeah you could
play anywhere collect tons of characters
and so engage your brain with fun
puzzles and collect tons of cute
characters trust me with over 100
million downloads this five-star rated
mobile puzzle game is a must play
download best fiends free on the Apple
App Store or Google Play
that's friends without the are best
fiends
yes V James II and a lot of times when
I'm playing games I like to have
beautiful luscious hair and how do i how
do I get beautiful function of beauty
now one size may fit all for your
accessories but when it comes to your
hair we all need something a little
different to help us look our best what
if your hair care was as unique as you
are how do you get one that's as unique
as me so function of beauty is a hair
care product that is formulated
especially for you you go on their
website you take a quiz telling them
what kind of hair you have first and
then what you want to change about your
hair personally for me I got a joy scalp
and my ends are really dry cuz I die the
heck out of my hair so I put that in and
no matter what your hair type is they
create a shampoo conditioner and
treatments to fit your unique needs
it has over fifty four trillion possible
ingredient combination formula is as
unique as you are so after you do your
quiz the beauty team from function
determines the right blend of
ingredients then bottle your custom
formula to order it is so custom you can
choose the color the smell I want to get
the black bottle next blow their
formulas are vegan and cruelty free they
never use sulfates parabens or any other
harmful ingredients then they deliver
your personalized formula right to your
door in a cute customized bottle with
your favorite color and fragrance the
name part is what gets me I just like
having my name on things so I got a
purple one with peach scent on it
a huge fan of peach but like I said the
next one I'm gonna go all black and
lately it's been helping like I don't
have my dry ends anymore so it doesn't
look like hay anymore gorgeous thank you
so what are you waiting for it go to
function of beauty calm slash big mood
to take your four-part hair profile quiz
and save 20% on your first order
that's function of beauty calm slash big
mood for 20% off and let them know you
heard about it from our show because
lets them know that you guys like us
once again that's function of beauty.com
slash big mood there's one time I tried
coke rich you know I've always wanted to
I it was in my early 20s and we like my
friends like you want to try coke I'm
like you know like yeah sure cuz like
I've always been curious of certain
drugs all the go-go dancers are on Co
not all a lot we're not I know one that
way frizzy on coke I don't think I think
they take longer performing drugs right
like ecstasy or something cuz coke is a
very short performing drug like you've
to constantly keep doing it so I think a
lot of them are on other stuff I only
knew one girl they had like a crazy coke
problem but I tried coke once and it's
once well this was in the beginning like
this it was my first time trying coke
and I was like ok let's see this I
didn't feel anything
you didn't feel anything old and then
just and then I did again I'm like maybe
I'm just not doing it right no should I
eat this around didn't work and then so
after the night at the club I go home
and then I was like mmm and then just
like instant projectile vomited into the
toilet I don't know why no well what
happened so the first time I tried it -
I was with my boyfriend when I was 18
years old and then we were all in the
his back yard there's like six or eight
of us we're in his backyard and we were
drinking the [ __ ] out of these beers
like total [ __ ] like white trash
scene everyone is Mexican except for me
but it was it was like a white trash
[ __ ] scene like everyone's just
drinking like straight like we had the
box of beers just like sitting in the
yard and we're all in lawn chairs and
we're just pulling beer after beer after
just cuz yeah and like we're just
[ __ ] getting trashed and then so we
started doing lines I was like I don't
feel anything either but like our
conversations were like so I was so into
our conversation like
we were just having a great asset once
over there no even a funny snow dude but
I think I probably drank like eight or
nine beers when usually I'm like a one
or two beer person so it just caused me
to drink more and I didn't even realize
it and then so that's why I like puked
so bad for like the whole like 24 hours
after because I didn't realize how much
I was drinking I didn't drink I
literally just did Coco felt nothing
came home projectile vomiting and what's
a bit I didn't eat anything or something
did you ever try it again if and then
years years years after I tried it again
I'm like this just so he tries again
still nothing one coke does nothing for
me I have no idea why we're yeah take
new forms of like a methamphetamines no
like an adderall adderall is very
similar the adderall might work for me
yes did you eat any eggplant before you
did the coke because last time no the
last time I threw up I had eaten a plant
so maybe that is totally related for
sure and then like like weed makes me
throw up also I don't smoke weed weed
once during those crazy party days I
remember like someone who had a fat one
you know oh yeah those are nests
yeah those are so dirt I was throwing up
like coffee grinds yes that's blood [ __ ]
if you throw coffee grinds his blood oh
really yeah I just remembered one story
I I don't drink much and you guys know
this yeah the only time that I've
actually drink drink pretty often now is
during quarantine because you got
fuck-all to do mm-hmm probably the
craziest story I've ever had was in
Hawaii Hawaii yeah it's not what that's
though right okay um I was in Hawaii
just like visiting friends and we went
to a club I forgot which club it was um
this is like when I was like 24 25
whenever I go to Hawaii I stay at my
friend's house him and his wife they're
doctors right so they their house is
like just chock full of medication
whatever right anyhow so I go to a club
I don't really drink at all but then I
run into my girl she was like this old
school go to a go-go dancer she was like
our mother we call her mama her name is
Jerry Lee mm-hmm I know Jerry is yeah
yeah baby super sweet I love her and
when you run into one of your older like
your mama's Jerry can [ __ ]
that girl can drink and she's like oh my
god daughter and she's just handing me
shots and I don't say no to you know
it's just like a respect thing and I got
absolutely [ __ ] like bad [ __ ] host
[ __ ] house okay and my flight was that
morning at idiom right so did you make
it so I come home at like 3 or 4 in the
morning and I'm hugging my toilet just
vomiting right my friend wakes up he
comes in he's like oh my god and he's
like you look like [ __ ] I'm like I want
to die so he's like okay I'll be right
back he comes back with a syringe he
goes you ready for this I'm like what
the [ __ ] is that cuz remember he and his
wife or doctors oh [ __ ] this is so
exciting what is that you guys so this
is what we give it's an anti nausea
thing that we give to pay cancer
patients because chemo makes him sick
this helps them whoa and then so he jabs
into my arm injects me and I'm like oh
yeah and then he he gives me an adderall
he's like because you need to wake up
and go get your flight unfortunately it
didn't work quick enough I puked out the
adderall which is okay that's fine and
then I go and I pack my stuff now that
I'm not nauseated anymore and then I
realize my wallets gone I've lost it at
the club no I have no idea to fly home
or the doctor drugged you and stole your
wallet and that too that's how he makes
his money yeah so I was like [ __ ] how am
I gonna fly home and then I called the
airline they're like yeah you can't fly
without an ID dude so I figured okay
well I'm just gonna stay next few days
have someone overnight me my passport
from home or something my friends like
all right well since you're saying you
need sleep
here's a xanax I'm just reaching use an
axe I'm just like laying there just and
then I was like hey you know what I'm
just gonna call TSA just to make sure
and then so I called TSA and they're
like no I mean like you can fly if you
have like some sort of official credit
card any credit card official whatever
yeah they're like just file a police
report saying that you lost your wallet
and then come early and we're gonna do
extra screening security bring whatever
you have the has your name on it luckily
for me I had like my pharmaceutical
papers and my ID so I call the cops
it's like oh it's like five or six in
the morning at this point I'm always
annexed out barely asleep or barely
awake the cops come I'm standing outside
the building and like five cop cars come
and I'm just like bro what the hell
they're like yeah we're bored there's
nothing going on so there's like five
cop cars and then I go off to the
airport and I'm going through screening
just half asleep just like this is the
worst day of my life just I have no idea
what just happened last three hours and
I got home and I passed out and that was
the craziest party story ever
you're lucky I think that you were in
Hawaii because it's still like the
United States yeah imagine if you were
like somewhere outside of the United
States trying to get into the United
States not [ __ ] gonna have yeah
however told y'all my um my accidental
prostitute story in Vegas let me tell
yourself told the story plenty times on
my own [ __ ] so like if you're my fan
you've heard this story of so many times
but so I was in Vegas this is like the
first time all the homies were 21 right
we're like let's go to Vegas and so you
know of course the whole time we're like
oh so we thought we were ballin cuz we
got this like suite at the at the Luxor
that had like a hot tub a give me a
brand deal it was like four of us in
this room that had a hot tub in it like
and it's not like a separate outside the
hot tub like in the middle of the
[ __ ] like the room right so we're
like and we bought all these like bottle
of bottles of like I don't know Smirnoff
like vodka so um we're like okay we're
ready like [ __ ] have some girls in
struggle party Oh completely but we
thought we were balling right so the
whole weekend I'm trying to like
approach girls and like it kind of you
know it was a little success but not
really nothing ever really worked right
so the last night there I'm like man
[ __ ] this I'm gonna get a girl in here
like somehow right so so then I'm like I
didn't know this that you know if it's
like 1:00 a.m. 2:00 a.m. in Vegas and
there's a girl playing the slots by
herself like she's probably a prostitute
the processes are very low-key there I
didn't know that I mean I've said out
there and played the slots by myself oh
I'm not
you might have been but people have a
problem but it was like it was like cuz
I used to smoke cigarettes I don't smoke
anymore now but I used to smoke
cigarettes so in Vegas I would just
smoke a cigarette and be epic cuz I'm
just I can't sleep when I've been
drinking yeah yeah they thought you were
prostitute for sure they did well I seen
this I saw this pretty asian girl
chillin at the slots by herself I was
like I'm gonna say what's up right so
I'm like in my head I'm like okay I'm
trying to prepare something to say and
then I said some dumb [ __ ] I was like oh
so you you win in anything tonight
[ __ ] right he's gonna work no matter
what
yeah exactly easy so she's just like
she's like she's like me it's okay I'm
like okay well uh you wanna like you're
like hangout leader or something I got I
got like I got a bunch of you know
alcohol in my room we you didn't know
she was a process I know she's bossy I
was jumping just holler at this girl cuz
I thought like oh she's pretty she's by
herself you know so I was like hey so
you know I'm like if you're nothing to
do later you know um I got a hot tub and
we got alcohol in the room she's like
okay four Suites so I'm like this is so
easy easy I'm like are we just you know
she's like she's like okay communi like
sweet so you didn't think he's [ __ ]
him so she takes my number she takes her
so I put my number in her phone and then
I'm like cool I go back to the room I'm
like success I did it I'm a pimp and
then so everyone's like what you had a
girl come to the room is crazy like yeah
yeah so I'm cleaning the room and [ __ ]
right get it ready guys out no here's
the dumb part - everybody stayed in the
room Oh like yeah okay so she finally
calls me like an hour later cuz at first
I was like oh she bought the flake on me
so she calls me I'm like hello and she's
like hey you and um you gonna take care
of me tonight and I'm like yeah girl of
course what does that mean and then I
hang up and I'm like yo what if she's a
prostitute right cuz like take care of
me what the [ __ ] does that mean so but
I'm like whatever so and another I went
to go meet her it by the elevator she
got walked up I like two guys
she can't so we're going up to the room
and we go inside and my [ __ ] homies
are in there in the in the hot tub with
bubbles chillin in hindsight now I'm
like I probably should have kicked them
out you know but every was obviously
really quick [ __ ] like I remember like
my homie Eric like PD like super ego
like I remember these if I'm gonna have
like bubbles all in like I had so I'm
like a little side area where the drinks
were so I'm like I pour a drink and so
but I'm like yo is she a prostitute or
not so I'm like well can I ask you
something
and I'm like so are you here cuz you
wanna hang out like cuz just for you cuz
just cuz or are you looking to get like
compensated you know she's like okay
well um I'm an entertainer I was like oh
okay so I'm like okay well how much is
it she's like no no we don't talk like
that I was like okay well I'm like she
goes she's like well okay let's do it
like this how much do you have
alright and I'm like alright well we'll
see 7:30 but I'm like we got we got this
we got this room with the hot tub I can
give you some free shampoo no we got all
this liquor nothing we were broke as
[ __ ] we were eating McDonald's that
whole weekend you know and so she's like
okay well it was nice meeting you I'm
like all right nice meeting you too and
I like my Walker out the door and then I
come back in I'm like yo she's a
prostitute
that's crazy so and then I'm trying to
walk her to the elevator to be nice and
then [ __ ] Rick he's so excited that
she was a prostitute and you don't mind
you were like 18 or 21 we're still like
young and stupid Rick is like he opens
the door he goes and he screams down the
hallway he's like yo prostitutes are the
[ __ ] well that was nice
and that was it oh but here's the crazy
[ __ ] the extra crazy [ __ ] like years
later I forget the exact details of it
but I think Rick was in Vegas doing some
like a slum evant with somebody and some
guy was like yo you know what's crazy is
um you know if you need girls out here
let me know because you know a few years
ago your boy Tim actually was about to
take one of my girls like a fan of mine
hook you up like hey I'll pay for this I
guess not not a good fan [ __ ] now so now
there's a rumor that Tim put the
prostitute Annie's broke up pretty sure
she gave him the deep down in five
minutes but yeah we had a similar story
I went to Vegas with a bunch of my guy
friends and then we there was this cute
asian girl I was just chillin by herself
like oh she's cute and then my friends
started talking to her and you know you
do the whole Vegas thing like just
[ __ ] like oh my friend's a Korean
star or a star in China or whatever
she's but she was kind of like Asian
Fabi didn't speak English very well she
said Wow really comes back to our room
like yeah we got it in and she goes and
then we started to finally realize she
wanted some sort of compensation we're
like oh she's like lingering like yeah
oh they [ __ ]
no no they didn't [ __ ] but and then like
she got kind of like impatient she's
like I'm gonna leave and she's like can
you guys pay for my cab and we're like
how much my caption was five hundred
dollars like a cab is five hundred
dollars yeah we're like no sorry we're
not paying for that and she's [ __ ]
left we had no it issues possible but no
one smashed no no no you can't tell
because they just like when people think
prostitutes they think like on TV
walking the streets with like 17 inch
heels and [ __ ] but they're just 2 a.m.
and the slot machines mm-hmm yes yes so
you're talking about hotel rooms with
hot tubs like one of my crazier party
stories was when I was 15
I was living in Mexico I would party a
lot like corn and raise corn rice corn
at remarries I'm sorry I can't help it
yeah so my sisters and I we would party
like every almost every night that we
could and so the the procedure there was
okay first we're gonna go to a club and
I would get like a fake ID cuz I was 15
and the legal age out there is 18 and so
so we they would get me into the clubs
like a guy in our group would like pay
the door yet whatever I'd get in we
would be clubbing it up after the club
closes at 2:00 that's when someone in
our group would be like alright I'll get
the room and so we would go to these
specific hotels that they have in Mexico
I had no idea and this is what these
hotels are for because the way that they
would work is a whole bunch of us would
like try to stuff ourselves into the
trunk and like hide in the car because
you would drive you would drive up to
this hotel and the hotel guy would be
like well how many people are with you
okay and they charge per person and then
you tell them how long you're gonna be
there so it's hourly and and then once
they give you the room key you drive up
to the room and if the room is like a
garage so you're like when you're
driving in it's to a garage and then you
go upstairs and that's your hotel room
and it's so private so secretive that if
you order room service there's this
window there that like it spins and so
that was the usual thing that we would
do almost every night or every weekend I
know it was [ __ ] wild when I was 15
I'm like holy [ __ ] a lot of people don't
experience this [ __ ] but so we would do
that we would get our shits in a beer
and then also like the stores would be
closed so then the guys they knew like a
particular liquor store that they would
go to where they like tap on the window
and then like the guy would come out and
like give us like cases of beer and then
like and then we'd take off but like
they're not even open they're just be
tapping on the window it was like really
like underground [ __ ] so then we would
party it up all the time like this and
one time we did get a hot tub and and
then like people started trickling away
and then by the end of the night it was
me like my sister had already left so it
was me
a girl and a guy and another guy right
this other guy had passed out drunk he
was on like the couch in like the living
room area he was gone I kept drinking
and and then so the other girl and the
guy they got so [ __ ] wasted that they
ended up going to the bed and like the
Hudson was here like the bed was like
you can literally like just [ __ ] it I
was in the hot tub watching porn for
some reason it was playing on the TV and
I was just like this is interesting
that's the first time I've seen porn and
thrown into this life do you name it was
intense and so as I'm watching porn
they're over there having sex and I'm
like wow I was just like I was trying
really hard not to see cuz I was like
this is [ __ ] weird
and I know the girl is just like
embarrassing like in it it was it was
like really um really intense really I
think traumatic that's how you
celebrated your Atkinson yet man like
those parties would get so crazy too
because sometimes like people would
bring their like they had to pick up
their kid from the babysitter it's a
random baby sleeping there's a random
baby there quite like prostitute hotels
and I'm like this is [ __ ] wild and
then those same people though like it'd
be one weekend where we'd go to like the
Banda clubs or like the hip-hop clubs
and then do the hotel thing or another
weekend would be like okay we're gonna
go camping now in a valley because
there's this three-day rave happening
and we're just gonna be on ecstasy the
entire weekend so that was like my life
what's xse in Spanish yeah no I don't
remember
what's the crate like have you ever been
to a party like you don't want to kill
it participate in drugs or anything what
have you ever seen anything that was
like [ __ ] weird or crazy at a party
or yeah at a party at a party or a clip
okay you wanna hear craziest thing I
ever saw
at a club party reason why I don't do
drugs his uh I was at some club and
literally a dude started like foaming at
the mouth and like
on the floor and you saw that because it
scared you away for scared away early so
you didn't have to do yeah I mean we
were like okay yeah never never doing
that so I got that definitely scared us
away
oh absolutely there reminds me every
time I think of that I think of bad boys
when that guy was dying in the club he's
like this [ __ ] not dying in my
club and they toss him in the back of
the alley
I remember one time I was go-go dancing
it was at an event called I think was
fresh this is like it one of those EDM
events and there was this really cool
couple that was hanging out in the
adjustment like it's a big event so our
dressing room is huge because we have so
many performers like circus performers
and go-go dancers and there's this
really cool couple that we met and we
were just hanging out talking and she's
like yeah we just had our baby like you
know a month ago whatever she brings out
her titty pumping milk thing and she
starts pumping and which is cool like
look man go-go dancing scene for raves I
was the only Asian girl the rest were
all white white people are crazy
mmm like it's I like people who party or
crazy especially hippy white people
Burning Man
yeah like Burning Man folks amazing but
she's like pumping titty milk and then
her husband comes over he said babe you
want some she goes oh yeah oh whoa whoa
you think she was put cause like when
you drink or do drugs or things like
maybe you got you pumped to throw it out
so I was like I don't think she was
giving that to her baby so I was just
like uh but you're pumping I don't want
to tell you how to live your life but
you're pumping milk for your baby she
goes oh no no it's cuz it gets so
engorged and heavy I dump it out she's
gonna discard that I'm okay God but that
was the weirdest I've never liked hell
now I can say that I've seen a woman
pump breast milk while doing a line of
coke with her husband it was very
romantic
- it is crazy I'd give it up you ever
tasted your own titty milk mm-hmm what's
it taste like it's like like cantaloupe
I want to try it was like Kendall yeah I
heard it's sweet it's really sweet that
grosses me out so much - if you like in
the back drink it I got him a cup I just
like I was like oh [ __ ] some slip I'm
like that's it's so weird because I
drink milk from cow tits but thinking
about drinking milk from you I guess
it's like the whole cannibalistic vibe
don't care I'm a cannibal next time when
y'all get pregnant
whoever gets pregnant for us Nicki I'm
talking to you - you can charge it and
she I want to try your titty milk right
now I will do a YouTube video if I have
to oh yeah and do coke when you pump it
for cantaloupe flavored milk laced with
cocaine just makes so much money my club
drug guys it's called coca-cola I think
that's about all the time we have today
I didn't even get to any of mine crazy
how many more - I know there's a lot
baby we could do part - we can't extend
it okay it's okay it's okay we can have
we can have a part - do you know what I
mean anyway so thank you guys make sure
you go follow tim on all of his stuff I
think it's what youtube.com slash
Timothy yes you to become system of the
Instagram tim chantarangsu guess and if
you don't know how to spell that all the
links will be in the description box
below thank you for coming on our show
it was great make sure to subscribe to
our YouTube channel also to iTunes or
anything like that leave us a review it
really helps the show it really helps us
with our advertisers also if you use our
code so get you something that we have
anyways thanks guys see you next week
and just as not a prostitute I'm not a
process